at hairspray to get your life together
I'm not touching
hot in here man it is hot and her what's
up bro
what'd you do with the shades on you
want me to top gun are we shooting Top
Gun foreign stuff sack so what we're
doing I just got off set of Top Gun for
do dude honestly like an like a blind
guy that's a flat like kind of like once
a gamble look like Top Gun for bro bro
you look like bottom gun zero [ __ ]
wear sunglasses inside my head keep them
off like yeah dude that's a Larry David
you look is that a onesie you have one
it's a romper bro it's hot girls I'm
also selling skinny Tina on Instagram
and they got a clawed ass what's up bro
you got a problem with the romper dude
how long I've been searching for this
thing how would I wore it last night I
went last night to the Comedy Store and
you know what everyone has terrible
fashion so I don't give a [ __ ] I know
people make fun of me we're all sitting
back there and then I was and then bill
burr walks I was like [ __ ] and usually
he just looks at me and goes you just
looked at me goes you look like a
mechanic from a musical last night there
we have phantom of the shop or a family
khakhra body shop we're done my last
night there talking about King this
thing in this row see each other and
they set out out of your friends some
Brandon dude back there said your
friends who roast you the were so it oh
it's not even close
I said you told me I look like the other
make smooth he's for sure a hit the
stage last night I go I know I look like
a Nordstrom mechanic I'm very aware
dude I think you credit for that
okay good good you see using my jigs on
stage but I just can't believe you're
dressed in a well I can't believe you're
dressed like a job you probably never
had that's the worst part dude that's
duckies no no oh but no if I'm gonna
wear it's not gonna be Dickie or I can't
even add a key or to dig in hard-working
blue-collar pendant light blue collars
the best you would do
baby blue collar I was a janitor though
good job as a janitor wet yeah
Albertson's it's like it would it be
like Ralph's here do you it's yeah it's
a grocery store you don't know what
Albertsons I don't know what we're
talking about there's Albertsons
everywhere
it's with say it's worldwide worldwide
nationwide mr. Allens world walk the
planet into Florida
we're talking to bro Brendon Limited
Maps over years job you got a bad globe
it has two continents on it yeah and one
of the comments is a David buss but it
just says Dave and busts but I wish you
had your hair out man get a haircut
uh-uh wash my hair though how expensive
we ought to by the way from Patrick
Swayze
[Laughter]
okay hush it's real it's real it is real
bro feel like I haven't seen you a while
man we do the show I feel you dude how
you doing brother doing pretty good man
are you chilling I got this new Rat King
hitter right the merch I see I see you
with the side hustle having lunch with
your little twink okay can we get a
different model God look less thirsty or
that models
it's like oh my god deal I don't want to
buy this because I'm definitely a gay
aftertaste breath you looks like a
souvenir from a [ __ ] glory hole after
I get done dude okay I'll take one of
those every kind everything you end up
talking about how's your wiener in it
sometimes I wieners yours bro
well somebody somebody's well we'll say
this dude yeah those some of those items
definitely rather homoerotic dude those
the shorts we have you put them on and
there's another dude in them already
warm yeah it's not yeah dude I can't
believe uh I can't believe our nuts last
so long can you believe that
what do you mean like our nuts for our
body you know yeah may get bigger over
time yeah you're not you're not so good
damn bro so Derrick got some bangers
yeah yeah I believe Derrick is not as
big nuts yeah he's nuts lats how you
know that Derrick's more than a friend
to you if you know that it's not slap I
know dude I'm aware I talked to this
girl about busting us every episode this
ends in a big bust
the other day I walked out here and
slipped and hurt myself this place drive
this room up dude you guys need to get
Christ to and Derrick should have some
church and yeah you could use the little
church demon that's a lot of these new
brothers brothers no there's no the Lord
ain't in there there ain't they
there's about busting nuts and gold
chains yeah do they're all Trinidad
James or whatever that guy is you know
what was his name Gold all of my braids
you know gold all in my veins I'm like
dude you'll get mercury poisoning
yeah that make sense does it what was
that I know you're referring to uh
what's-his-name
Sean Kingston hit him with the damn jet
ski or something killed him how many
guys that fella killed do Sean Kingston
from the Bahamas or Z Jamaican nah dude
they said he was in Germany he had a
lisp but he just really rammed that
Jamaican themed indie what was his Sean
Kingston's number-one hit huh
he had some bad you're speaking of
slapping nuts he had some bangers you
guys are disgusting
what was Sean Keats's number-one hit
yeah beautiful girl why you know like
Magic Johnson that's a young Magic
Johnson this tragic Johnson on a jet ski
dude Jamaican Johnson oh yeah Wow
beautiful guy bro you got stung by that
Jamaican wasp though do you think he can
hoop or not absolutely not him and
Chappelle it discord be two to one in
two hours think you didn't get through a
game of horse I'm good to be you're good
to see you guys Derek and cat good to
see you buddy culture corner yeah what's
happening over there oh nothing I did
some Joe Rogan and Friends last night it
was awesome oh really
that was fun Brendan was that dude at
one point it's a tailed Bill Berg Ali
Wong everybody's just in the green room
and Simmons was telling stories about
Patrice it was just [ __ ] and I'm in a
romper really and I'm another rockin
romper not shocked bro I know you not
yeah no but I feel comfortable around
you
huh I feel comfortable wearing this
round you know that sentence seem like
yeah if I get caught up on a turn
somewhere
[Laughter]
you owe me say this who you say you feel
comfortable around me in that
Patrice O'Neal huh oh yeah Simmons
because you know him and him Joe and
they all started in Boston Fitzsimmons
so he was telling us great Patrice
O'Neal sir and Patrice were close Oh
burr Patrice close Fitzsimmons and
Patrice they started to open mics
together I love birds take on louis c.k
and just all that stuff man
are in the pain the greener man what uh
what a put trees died of diabetes
african-american death in the world I
grow they write your own death I know if
you just eat right you watch Amy Sherman
died of it now in a couple of years so
probably get her leg taken off [ __ ]
comes out as gay you know my mouth tour
where she has like a [ __ ] mustard and
ketchup dang man well that's awesome
that's crazy yeah being in that
environment when there's like somebody
just just killers they were beasts was
awesome that's crazy what if so yeah
what if a missile would hit or something
you know well we saw yeah Chappelle's
I'm gonna kill Chappelle you're good
who's Chapelle Lacey no she pal
Bilborough I think long somebody killed
bill burr I think bill burns number one
yeah yeah but at least she still has
Chappelle
yeah bit birds number one to me by yeah
different depend on your flavor Chapelle
Bilborough Louie CK man those are those
three first of all how's the Amazon fire
throws a rain forest fires not gonna
travel that fast also you're not getting
my money you guys could you use a little
less acai you feel me
if you guys are back off that coke I
know but are you alright right you
realize that you can't burn down a rain
for a dude you guys are coked up trying
to burn down these goddamn water just
surfing all the goddamn time no one's in
jeopardy yeah why don't I throw a couple
of awkwafina's into the fireplace and
start a real roaster you can't [ __ ]
do it okay Liars over there I agree I'm
not buying it dude get me out of this
book show me a burning tree frog [ __ ] my
face warming climate change do you think
warming global you know dude you don't
think they want beaches in Alaska
everybody's ready for their terms
think they wait for beachfront property
that's what they're waiting for you
dummies throw anchors Cavins turn into
beachfront but your thoughts out there
an anchor is walking up and down the
beach talk about the polar bears gonna
die yeah those things are [ __ ] a
nightmare they're gonna die or die I'm
gonna die looking at big tits dive
sunscreen [ __ ] poison yeah coca-cola
yeah those Polaroid is always drinking
coca-cola yeah those polar bears want to
brown around a little they want to be
brown bears you don't think they want to
[ __ ] take a little cruise to the
states on one of those glaciers
everyone's for global warming bro well I
don't want a bunch of it but I say a
little every now and then yeah a little
melty milking every passing years bro
heat it up that's what I said more water
the better bro oh my god really
I'm about to woman up Chris that's
what's born to do that was the jam criss
cross make you jump [ __ ] good God
warming bro why not yeah a little just
all I'm saying is a tad heated up a time
yeah let's warm it up pressure man makes
diamonds could be in [ __ ] yeah polar
bears kill everything yeah you think
they're nice bears they show them having
a soul and you know lounging around you
know having a snow cone or something
yeah ain't real man making eye sees
that's all [ __ ] white house
propaganda don't hang out with a black
bear they're not fun either dude that's
not a racist an or doing diabetes
playing dominoes I don't trust them
hibernating sleeping all the time yeah
all right man that's trick daddy now
it's everyone's favorite time it's a
commercial from King in the state bro
yeah the time is here it's football
season
Oh Browns on the Raiders I think it an
infection ah but I'm so Krunk for
football dude the Bell you talk you talk
about Bell it's levian I come at all
yeah first of all Bell let go el Bell
yeah you can't just put a comma if you
weren't your name okay it's kind of
confusing yeah it's kind of cut fusing
bro there you know dude Odell Beckham
the Browns that's my team this year by
grabs on the Raiders those are my two
teams I'm from Denver so we'll take you
listen listen if you want to make money
bro
I'm the sin FL season go to my bookie
it's the place to bet on football every
weekend my bookie has better bonuses and
more props better than any other sports
book period yep and this year they're
hosting the first online handicapping
super contest first place is guaranteed
to win at least $100,000 it only costs
$100 to enter all you got to do is pick
five NFL games against the spread every
week to climb the leaderboard and score
your share of the huge cash prize pool
so that's pretty that's pretty feasible
party dough man you know football you
follow football why not make a little
cash arena while you're doing it and
listen I use them so that's why I
recommend it to all the king in
stingless times that's why my bookie is
always the right play you bet you win
they pay period my book is live in game
betting on every NFL game that's
National Football League they got the
most rewarding player perks in the
business is you know what I'm saying is
Larry Fitzgerald gonna you know will he
spit out his gum he's like honey who
knows a 40 on it bro who knows bro but
if you keep been like that since
Stanford not for long if you keep them
for that you're casting to be around
very long
yeah this is a weak [ __ ] fall out the
stands dude into the parking lot you
know at a Bills game our players gonna
take a knee late 3000 you know I know
let's play ball well Kaepernick play
this year [ __ ] doubt it bro
you know please people that can play
brother $1,000 first deposit bonus
double your first deposit get paid use
promo code cats to activate the offer
visit my bookie online today that's em
ybo okay ie and don't forget to use the
promo code cats when you create your
account to claim the bonus bet when get
paid if you like gambling then this
could be a good experience for you my
bookie komm promo code cats someone's
got to pay for Brennan's coffee habit do
I keep telling you bro transformation is
important part of our lives especially
us man our careers what do you tell
always evolving dude and growing which
makes our life's pretty interesting our
sponsors for this segment I've talked
about Wix invites you guys the listeners
the watchers to tell the story of your
career transformation visually by design
your new homepage on Wix wakes up Wix
down boy get your Wix up now Wix is a
place where you can build a website for
something for yourself for a business
for a company I wish we'd known about
Wix when we're building our way me too
man and listen they got the school
competition going on right now we're
encouraging the king of sting listeners
to build their websites right now
creative homepage a homepage that
highlights why your career journey is
unique just like you guys Wix is the
free platform that empowers you to build
a highly customizable robust website
dude busted
email submissions to Wix WI X loves LOV
es cats K ATS at gmail.com I spare and
the mouse is a humorous homepage that
promotes a new podcast understated but
cool the first thing we see is an
eye-catching image of a bear on the left
of the screen on the right half
elizabeth clearly indicates the name of
her project what's it about
an Instagram link and a contact email
and just below the fold there's some
brief but informative copy about the
founders and their plans for ramping up
the business it's a fun and inviting
homepage one that generates interest in
using visuals nice we'll review the best
submissions from you in each of the next
five episodes and the six episode will
announce the grand prize winner of the
Wix business VIP premiere plan free for
one year a value of over four hundred
and twenty dollars I know we have a lot
of creative
Katz's viewers yeah I can't wait to see
I'm about to bust once again the URL is
wix.com slash go slash cat's submit your
best homepage to Wick's loves cats at
gmail.com your busts gusting someone got
spayed forties haircut yes i started off
a little tried my ride chopped my ride
baby but first with this is Riley Hobbs
from Berkeley California
this is Riley's gonna [ __ ] watch too
much National Geographic apparently
truck look at them zebes on the front
right zebras in the front Trump in the
back try Wow
oh it's a [ __ ] Trump thingies guys yeah
you got it
you can you can miss me with the whole
political [ __ ] but I like the zebra [ __ ]
see ya yeah the look at the zebras
little stuff you can't have that car and
people aren't gonna take you serious so
it doesn't matter what message you have
on there also gluing all the zebras on
the car let me guess
single let me guess single let me guess
you give all your money to the [ __ ]
National Wildlife Association who just
steal it oh yeah and buy hair spray yeah
they put that take that [ __ ] man well
dude a lot of the cats they're giving
them pills and stuff in Japan and they
if you haven't seen any of those a lot
of the animals I think we talked about
it they got hung out the mouth they
can't see or any other visions going on
the Chinese are over there doing photos
with them yeah they are man their
[ __ ] given the Tigers nyquil and [ __ ]
and look at these zebras bro bro also
chill out on the zebras look at the
goddamn garage zebras aren't endangered
matter of fact we should kill more of
these guys there dude turn on National
Geographic
they're everywhere yeah the lines like
dude give us a [ __ ] break they're
impossible to kill you can't see them
and it's uh yeah color-block it depends
that's why they have stripes that's why
the stripes bro they're hard to see in
nature oh did you know that I know
you're trying to convince me other dude
I watched Planet Earth seasons 1 & 2 so
suck my dick suck this spotted zebra
dick bro I want to see planet Earth
after this climate change baby that's a
Waterworld too baby buzz water water
that's the real planet Earth I'm gonna
see just a couple of [ __ ]
smoked a cigarette out there on a
pyramid let me do the smart one with
gills a cricket or a baby elephant using
that [ __ ] tusk is a snorkel bro
straight smoke getting rocks in that
[ __ ] like the women what those 4x4 Land
Cruisers - snorkel baby just [ __ ]
cooking buds on the end of that thing
man I can't believe more Anton they
don't have more elephant smoking dope
brah you know put a screen in the end of
that into that snout and just cook a big
gram on there well that's a brilliant
idea then just see him [ __ ] wig the
[ __ ] out in Africa what if you just
started playing the trumpet out of this
[Laughter]
[ __ ] here we go
here we go this elephants on meth dude
try it out don't knock it till you try
it
also listen again there's two main
zebras their thing is why don't we own
more zebras when we domesticate zebras
dude they look cool you can ride on
their wildest [ __ ] are they rideable
have you ever seen anyone write a zebra
no you can write a dots and we still
have a little small boy boss who was
real strong and he would ride on one of
those dogs no I think it was like an
Australian Shepherd yeah if they're
strong enough this I mean these are
pretty strong man Australian Shepherd
they came all the way from [ __ ]
Australia yeah you right they made it in
getting a weak-ass little you know
yeah the weak ones died well some of
them you know I'm saying you don't see
like a uh you you don't see like a
Egyptian you know dog over here cuz then
[ __ ] I can't make there are different
cats though you know hey this lady with
the whole zebra thing there's a man huh
is this this our dude this is a Riley
actor
Riley's probably dude probably do the
one just like balding lives in sweats
all the money goes National Geographic
Association bus nuts to zebras you can't
wait for the next documentary to come
out I'll tell you this Joe or I'm gonna
stay here and eat it one percent and
then pic and then post a picture on
Instagram of how tasty it is Cameron
Haynes would grill the backseat of this
[ __ ] car and eat that they really
would say you got some real hitters brah
thank ya dude I think ya be safe out
there if you find a chick that will bang
in the back of this dude you got a
keeper dude you got to keep her quiet
bro cause it's the same kind of chick
that's probably gonna file a file a
lawsuit against you let me to move yeah
just because you and the zebra a lot of
chicks won't even [ __ ] les there's a
me too at the end of it especially in
San Francisco yeah good luck out there
buddy yeah shoutout to zebras hopefully
we help good next what's he looking for
a relationship advice no that was just
his she wanted his ride tried it that's
all
Chad my ride yeah up next this is
Brandon sitting in Willis's Jeep his
uncle Willis is Jeep Palin goddamn
Willis 1958 trying to gain that trying
to be an extra in Mad Max - I feel bro
uncle Willis's Jeep will beat the [ __ ]
out of that first vehicle yeah well
that's for sure this thing's frosty dude
it's probably this thing probably runs
on straight-up hard wieners bro
testosterone [ __ ] you that thing is doe
well this thing probably runs on deck at
200 brah you ain't lyin bro fine sting
parked out front of a gold gym most
likely but the seat smell like wind
straw brother thing is he spent the last
five years building this bad boy himself
no this is a picture right here with a
transmission blew out oh this guy's wife
is missing under there because if you
have that much time to build this dude
your wife is missing yes something's
going on you're what I'm saying for some
yeah well she probably oh he's always
like yes you went to the stream to get
water
we haven't seen her in a couple years
she'll be back though yes sure he says
she'll be back sure Willis sure well if
she's in the garage Rothstein Forensic
Files she's in the garage bro I'm
guessing this thing has no radio none
none of that [ __ ] this is just the nitty
gritty mad max-style
oh this this dude probably got some 22
inch Python arms no sleeves ever jean
shorts probably got his little twink and
the other [ __ ] shotgun and they're
just road tripping and suckin bro he
really hit it Willy
[ __ ] yeah well that's we good effects
this is Chris he's sitting in his
neighbor's car from Van Nuys this is
Chris [ __ ] yeah hell yeah and this I
think this cars lorries and vibin let's
go to cat on this you think asian a
little what do you think cat I don't
know what it is honestly when the agent
about it to you yeah I don't I get a
just like the it's kind of a little bit
lower it feels like those rims are Asian
II yeah it feels like it there's a plan
that it's almost done it's like a work
in progress
Oh to me it feels like a white dude who
really likes asian girls
yeah yeah he's signaling to them like
he's trying to be Asian secretly but on
the low yeah warts little bow-wows these
just fell on hard times all just trying
to get recognized from Fast and Furious
or too little bow you know like Asians
you know yeah you're right just a guy
who likes ages a little bow a little bow
and just hangs out in front of karate
schools trying to pick up the young
chicks yeah hey [ __ ] belts out of his
[ __ ] trunk you want to get high yeah
hi-yah girl mister hi-yah your girl yeah
and this is a Ford Taurus isn't no they
ain't no Taurus is it ain't nothing a
genetically do why yeah there was always
white dudes that wanted to be black when
I was growing up always drove Ford
Taurus as I feel like why do you want to
be black yeah that's for Eclipse that
was another car the clips were popping
when we were growing up dude what else
uh the sabers always kind of been there
the sabers that he had a lack that was
for a dude who had a dad that family had
a little bit of money though if they got
the white oh you're balling on urban or
you got that PT Cruiser for a little bit
oh that was Tom that's it was Adams
family vibes yeah I was a creepy ride as
a kid man yeah I'm trying for y'all what
this logo is on the side here man it's
good
get some business not doing very well
it's tough in the streets bro what was
his name
this is Chris's neighbors cars his next
his neighbor might be a [ __ ] one of
those real life superheroes too you know
look at that but here now look at the
rim on that look at that what they call
it the rice rim or something on the back
what's that thing at the top though
that's broiler I didn't even see that no
that's what I'm saying I think that's
why I came a little bit you know 60%
dude yeah yeah [ __ ] sesame chicken
you know this thing smells like egg
rolls oh yeah bro yeah this guy
definitely has a little bit of General
Tso's in the trunk well sweet and sour
at the back you know I'm saying yeah let
me see the whole vehicle with and look
how the do I'd even see that the oh yeah
that thing is fast and furious up your
eyes bro this is Vin Diesel do hard to
see out of that [ __ ] tight-ass onesie
huh yeah it's cut off the circulation
Robert ain't cutting off the circulation
[Laughter]
you're a [ __ ] bro you would definitely
be the first guy to get [ __ ] at a
Sherwin Williams right now what of the
handles match that thing match the yeah
it seems like it's a project for him
it's just he's trying to get to it you
know he's going to Pep Boys once every
three four weeks buying parts buying
paints and it's a project that's what's
going on there
this looks like tiresias car from fast
and furious ruin Tyrese needed money was
like begging real Smith on Instagram
yeah like melting really yeah Marley
rope and then Will Smith gave him money
damn yeah it was great what's his name
was eating Vaseline that time when
YouTube he was having a tough time
Stephon Marbury oh yeah he was eating
Vaseline yeah let me think about Amanda
wait a minute Rose who is that man
amanda Bynes was eating I don't know
well but this is yeah this looks like
the whoever is like the ulysses s grant
or the people that are storming area51
this looks like yeah
yeah here's an ad dude support for king
of sting comes from manscaped well you
know what dude my crotch is looking nice
boy I got that fade I got they call it
filly fade on my landscape who's the
number one in men's below the belt
grooming manscaped offers Precision's
tools for you jewel you got cornrows are
on your cornhole somebody says yeah I
got braids out the back fades in the
front because when you're when you're
not using manscape and you try to cut
them ball nickim those things bleed
forever dude my bleeped out bro Oh bro
I'll predict the future right now call
me next Radames growth you Nick your bag
dawg
you're gonna bleed out front yeah man
don't use the same trimmer use on your
face on your balls what are you doing
that's nasty and I'll use a knife Rud
and cleaner on your crotch dude tighten
up with manscaped accidents are a thing
of the past manscaped has that crop
preserver yeah I get 20% off right now
in free shipping with the code cats at
manscape calm always use the right tools
for the job
yep your balls will love it yep they got
the skin safe technology trimmer so you
can't even clip your nuts if you wanted
to break a try all afternoon try you
want or get that Philly fade on your
nutsack get 20% off and free shipping
with the code cats at man Scoob calm
that's 20% off free shipping at manscape
com use code cat and you can also trim
elections a little extra hair to give
you a junk that thicker fuller look give
it an afro yeah get 20% off and free
shipping with code cats Kay 80s at
manscape com trying to keep lights on I
just got this pretty good dude I got it
and I [ __ ] forgot about I didn't know
what it was doing on my porch stinks did
you forget to bring your hellofresh
indoors in your porch stinks well that's
on you Brad towing that stuff in that
box is fresh France you open up says
hello it's delicious the lamb jumped
right out of this box into my kitchen
dude organic - yeah he said now I've
been feeding goat milk daddy got a pet
hello fresh makes cooking delicious
meals at home a reality regardless
you'll have to be an expert you know if
you know Wolfgang Puck it step-by-step
recipes pre-measured ingredients so you
have
everything you need to get it going yep
get your nuts in your hand brother and
make a choice what I'm saying is this if
you have a friend or a family member and
you want to make some food together
hellofresh is a great way to spend time
with somebody that you care about to
teach a child to cook you got a little
child or you got a small friend or a
family member that's real small or
regular-sized you can cook with them
just a human and generally get cook with
them yeah whatever you want to do man
and listen they have something for
everybody they got a vegetarian whatever
you want a little brat
you got some steak with brats worst baby
they got everything they got the
Filipino they got the vegan they got the
Familia they got it all do Italian do
Meraz delicious simple a delectable bro
add extra meals to your weekly order if
you want easily change your delivery
days food preferences whatever you want
they got calories smart they got
vegetarian dude you hungry you not
hungry who gives a damn
hello fresh yeah who gives a damn hello
fresh is right for 80 dollars off your
first month of having fresh go to hello
fresh dot-com slash cats 80 enter code
cats 80 yup that's right
eighty dollars off your first month of
hello for 80 smackers off your first
month of hello fresh go to hello fresh
calm / K 80s 8-0 and enter k 88 0
support the podcast of next debate club
up first
ja'crispy savage ja'crispy I'm already
liking this bro I know them oh and they
cut it off we said buzz Bob he's about
the youth of the buzz and he didn't very
unique I like that you have you the
mystery finished there's this thing ends
he's still alive I feel is this
family members at Amelia Earhart finish
right there yeah we don't know what
happened you know uh I met them in
Atlanta after the show trust like this
dress exactly like yeah they wear this
all the time when they are I thought it
was lesbians brother far away because I
member seated they were in the distance
for the audience that's fair and then I
met them after the show man they were
really really cool I was just exhausted
I wanted to engage with them a little
bit more I would say most of my life I
do catch up but I'll go mustard now and
I will actually get mustard and put
honey in it and put real honey in it so
also known as honey mustard yeah Jesus
Christ bro
yeah Brendan welcome to 2019 like your
breaking news here good god what I like
to do it's pretty unheard of
I'll take mustard I put honey in it yes
you really try it out honey mustard
anyway a fan of yellow mustard because
as a Kido kid I'm wearing this romper
kid mustard no sugar ketchup a lot of
sugar also a little fat for your dumb
ass Brittany gets an idea first of all
you can see how idea just act like you
solved the world's bronze because you
invented honey mustard just do their mom
think imitation I didn't put it in the
work Brendan I mix honey and mustard I
don't buy I'm already mixed like some
loser that's what I'm saying they do the
work okay
I'm gonna rest like it onesie [ __ ]
McGillicutty over there where's your
broom at Big Daddy huh food dressed like
you I can work it don't work bro hey
what time are the SATs are you dressed
like this without matching sweaters bro
because they also are you the rock why
were your merch I'm sorry you Michael
Jordan problem who's your merger you
where in did
yeah wear your own bro all right Rock
keep wearing your own [ __ ]
yeah you don't catch up hazard small
crystal you stole his [ __ ] eye thing
from the rock and let's say that [ __ ]
right here you tell my brow lift
oh whatever that is bro well I mean do
and you haven't stole from Patrick
Swayze and dr. Bonnie another no one
says anything about that bro saw Dog the
Bounty Hunter at the airport I'll tell
you that yeah yeah okay twice now
yes CT whatever Wow okay now you know
what it's like to spend time with you
Brendan okay new idea
that's the same idea over ever again you
ever seen German you just told me
invented honey money no I said it to you
oh do you know what else I like to do I
like take water and I put flavoring in
there dude and a little sugar I call it
kool-aid you got a live bro you gonna
quit wearing your own merch and just get
out of your circle dude you and that
little twink film each other up buckle
bunnies trying to slag merch on the side
get your life together bro we're doing
our best
hey go sling [ __ ] honey-mustard
[ __ ] NASCAR buckle buddy
bro you look like a [ __ ] dude who
will not retire from Spencer's brother
you look like a [ __ ] you look like
somebody who definitely to Stu's worked
at Abercrombie and Fitch
out front of the store greeting people
for 30 years I did have that job you
know ketchup was getting two before
[ __ ] Einstein McGee over here don't
thought he developed honey mustard I've
seen my day John and it's gonna be kind
of fancy little spicy too you know I'm
saying he thinks I'm Stein McGee he
thinks Einstein was Einstein's first
name that's the best part of this whole
thing
it's here'll Einstein you idiot you're
an idiot there's a lot of bugs and
ketchup if you look up the stats how
many how many dead bugs are in ketchup
every bottle of ketchup it's like 30
insects in the factories all these bugs
and stuff it's just it's fact what
factories do you know they can't hop its
just flies in sure they can't prevent it
they get into the mix no they can
definitely provide shoes they can
prevent it look at Derek's looking it up
so he'll probably go
this is Food and Drug Administration
quite little tomato worms flies beetle
spiders and rat here are just a few
added ingredients that yangyang boy I'm
in there [ __ ] that's right son you [ __ ]
how do you do a sketch up bro huh
when would you like ketchup more than
mustard then if you got some rat in
there I don't like ketchup because it
just doesn't it doesn't even sweet bro
yeah it doesn't even taste like tomato
anymore stole his helmet on red yeah it
tastes like big red depend where you get
it yeah it tastes old-fashioned get a
certain point I'm like it's just from
the past it's like we got to evolve in a
new sauce as Brahma but that's that Zeki
bruh all right on to that tzatziki
zat Zeki is how you pronounce it dude
I'm not mad a little hummus
oh that's not a sauce bro I know I was
just saying I like hummus taziki's also
a yogurt it's really a psalmist dude who
I dude i hang out
an Indian on the road its wholeness his
name's dangerous Brown yeah I can't met
his little ass and you know what he's
missing a little bomb and ass I think I
think yeah I think he's gone AWOL
I think he's converted well what else we
got dude I'm with mustard most people
eat ketchup this is obviously a percent
that was a little close well dude catch
up to knees that's the thing at a
standard cat what do you guys you guys
are doing new sauces give us an update
cat yeah hon yeah I'm not not being
racist Asians like mustard right like a
spicy mustard Chinese people do yep you
got a Chinese basically let's be honest
brother they own the big home jaundice
brothers dude okay Chinese are really
the black people of Asia is that true be
Filipino yeah I can I can see that yeah
I feel like Filipinos are the Mexicans
of Asians yeah so there's a lot of them
and they work really hard yes yeah very
family-oriented very family ordered the
smiling people they call Filipinos a lot
of times I never met I've never met a
mean Filipino really mm-hmm that's my
dick training it's a philomene Oh - they
call him that
really boom race it roasted call me Ben
Askren you like mustard though cat this
is like Brendan hitting on a girl this
is a [ __ ] oh this is this is my
president feet hitting on asian girl
yeah yeah this new thing you should try
I take honey I take the mustard you're
not sign this NDA I call it honey
mustard
yeah and they love it what do you you
guys using over there cat on you guys a
very unique sauce sriracha okay
Vietnamese hot sauce I like so much that
is yeah a lot of sugar in that too you
know that yeah sriracha yeah you're a
straight [ __ ] dude I'll [ __ ] put
I'll had a couple of nerd ropes in my
[ __ ] you little [ __ ]
put one of those red vines up your dick
hole dude I ain't no hoe son you know
I'm Sam bro
yeah dude I'll [ __ ] put four packs of
[ __ ] uh Splenda under my tongue and
take a nap you [ __ ] yeah that's
cool bro you're aggressive with it man
boy I'll put two quarts of honey in my
ass how old boy you know saying to go
for a run is backwards that's still a
hitter bro
thank you later dude y'all afraid of a
little pocket sugar are you afraid of a
little sucrose big dough you never had
some pop rocks in your dick little [ __ ]
do I like nerds how [ __ ] oh [ __ ] the
teeth up though sprees bruh do dude
runts so good holla
strawberry run so why not make all
strawberries though cuz banana people
love the banana I like banana banana
strawberry get that lime out of my
[ __ ] family oh you like the line
sometimes when I feel like I gotta
[ __ ] change it up I'll get a lime one
but the bananas boy I like the banana DH
like the grape one Stewie you guys like
the great ones great well yeah Derek I
said you guys yeah my great my brain
work brought over the kill
that's two obviously I kill dude you're
right sorry Derek it's okay but what
else you got oh yeah this is up next as
our homie from Ireland hey what else you
in bed next deal barbecue sauce gagging
gagging balls buzz I've gotta miss you
in [ __ ] Dublin Theo
congratulations on your movie bro anyway
thanks Mary to fight Tommy Lee Jones or
Harrison Ford that happened it's called
the fugitive decided Harrison Ford 81 he
jumped out of the goddamn water fall cuz
I didn't do it
time we leave those I don't care and
they jumps really yeah here's some Ford
for the win it's also Harrison Ford
dude Indiana Jones what is Tommy Lee
Jones done anything's impressive men in
black what else
Tommy Lee juicing forward come on bro
Tommy Lee Jones that's his name yeah I
merely justify he's not a boxer you know
he's actor from in and black he's got a
shot Abe Lincoln Harrison Ford's a
senior citizen dude dude Tommy Lee Jones
is older is he yeah and his pizza face
what is Tommy Lee Jones can you bring it
up no country for old man's one of his
big ones Wow here's something else
that's not ringing a bell
and add milk or lean coach with Cedric
the Entertainer how dare you how do you
mean girl bring it on close it something
like that a buddy of Mines mom bang
Sinbad a long time ago damn I'm
surprised my mom didn't oh yeah it's
Sinbad bro
he's Sinbad and he claps do that time
Jones got nuts under his eyes here's the
thing about Harrison Ford bro look at
his eyes dude that's good that's how
you're gonna look deal
there's her glasses on he has and those
are the rims of them near that no
they're not dude those are his eyes well
Derek doesn't ever zooms on anything so
we have no idea these are yeah glasses
yes zoom in though there's nuts under
his eyes dude glasses or not they're
glad they're the bottom reflection of
glasses nobody has nuts under their eyes
dude unless they had they were in a fire
in the cop and the didn't do it on
purpose yeah looks like that somebody
out of you that guy looks a little bit
like me yeah he does he doesn't be
similar but what's his big bring up his
uh his credit I'm trying we're missing a
big one cuz it'll Tommy Lee Jones one
the biggest actors in the world
the fugitive standard yeah man I'm sorry
I'm not gonna be there in Ireland but
I'll come see you in January we're gonna
reschedule for January and I'm gonna say
this that their boys out there next
April are you buzz-buzz who Batman
Forever he was king of the Joker twoface
and I know he's two-faced in that yes
I'll take care of him for uh-oh blown
away he's amazing him blown away under
siege JFK the good one dude he had that
[ __ ] hit talkative Will Hunting bruh
but I'm gonna say the other cool I don't
know who would win dude a couple old
guys fight and if they're fighting in
real life or their characters of
fighting whoever's [ __ ] doesn't blow
out when they square up you know at that
age what are you gonna do bro yeah
they shouldn't be fighting yeah I think
if you really want him to fight man I
would watch him fight but god it's gonna
be I wouldn't watch from up close I
watched him far away yeah and also
Harrison Ford pretty old he's like
crashing planes all the goddamn time I
heard he's high
24/7 yeah they say he definitely prefers
a little bit reefer gets in his private
plane and crashed look I'd say Harrison
Ford brah if you'd like to drink and fly
planes do
that sounds like the most Irish thing
I've ever heard in my life No so he's
Indiana Jones bro yeah come on bro yeah
and he's uh he's crashing playing he's
dead he's living his life oh he's also
in the original Star Wars dude yeah yeah
what do we even talk about what are we
Tommy he's been to space yeah
what are you talking about here's some
for all gun gang bro what people pick
65% harrison is closer than I thought
yeah that is cool god bless Ireland dude
and God bless Scotland dude don't debate
abuse you ever buy something online
Brendan I mean yeah all the time dude
okay cool but so later and that you had
a they had a discount that you miss yeah
bro yes annoying you ever buy like a
little dragon statue and then you're
like aw dang could have got this for six
bucks got it for 19 yeah bye lava lamps
for $100 then find out they're a lot
cheaper down the road bro there's one
right behind you for free man Oh what
but honey is a free browser add-on that
finds you the best deals online I don't
have to worry about missing a deal
anymore it's that last moment before you
click buy you click honey it bills right
in your browser it's right there on your
like on your fusion Firefox or Chrome or
whatever then it's right there on the
bar and you're like oh boom let me see
if there's a better place I can get I
shop like normal and then honey handles
the rest yep if you're gonna buy like I
bought some new air pods the other day I
thought it was gonna be $219 rocket
honey
boom it's like oh you can save 16
percent I really a sweet deal
we're not tomorrow robbing the bee rip
drip so I saved I think maybe 44 dollars
or something using honey man and it's
just because I wasn't thinking honey
kind of it does a little bit of extra
thinking hold up honey saved 10 million
members an average of 28 bucks that's
crazy a lot of money in honey members
have already saved more than 800 million
dollars overall it has a hundred
thousand five star reviews on the Google
Chrome store here's the thing it's free
yep
- clicks install it's free up think
about saving money yeah there's no
reason not to use honey it's free to use
easy install and on your computer and
just two clicks so shop with confidence
get honey for free and join honeycomb
slash cats
yep that's join honey dot-com / k 80s Jo
I n H o n ey comm / k 80s the smart
shopping assistant
that saves you time and money when
you're shopping online knock knock who's
there
Pacey old Brendan alright boys ready for
a little relationship advice let's help
people dude what we do best is it I
think so maybe right actually bro we're
doing all right with from Aiden this is
from Aiden from Georgia
another mobi oh good I was into this
girl I found out was a lesbian and it
kind of sucked typically didn't work out
and then ever since then every girl I
went into I find out they're a lesbian
like no matter what I didn't even know
how that many lesbians existed but I'm
an art student you know these girls are
like not kind of butch but you know
weird hair colors we're clothing maybe
experimental socialism I guess my type
lesbians left or right and I don't knows
we do man help me break this curse I see
what's going on here let's me instead of
laughs listen quit hitting on girls with
the same haircut as Theo that's your
problem
the other thing is do you think that
maybe they're lying teak is just not
into you if it keeps happening they
might be lying dude they don't hurt your
feelings look man here's marking up the
wrong tree
a lot of lesbianism out there these days
and a lot of women that don't even know
if there are lesbians but have just been
you know listen in a Chelsea Handler too
much so you got a lot of like misplaced
you know sexual identity going on so hot
to be gay right now yeah and it sells so
it's also hot to just be an angry lady
who doesn't ever use her vagina for any
drinking on Twitter and they don't have
wind or to have children yeah you know
just to like accuse people of crimes
within that happened inside of it but
I'm saying this brother if you're at an
art school dude look if a lady has more
than if she hasn't bunch of paint in her
backpack dude
she probably lesbian rough dude if she's
rolling her jeans up and she has some
Doc Martens on and black [ __ ] nail
polish is he sucking tits this is easy
to figure it out bro bro there's no
Sherlock Holmes situation yeah analyze
what's going on
jinkers with a couple of [ __ ] with
more than one key chain on it dog no
dude if she has a Green Day shirt
probably sucking tits bro yeah if she
sees you with a hot chick and [ __ ]
goes like this no does that mean it's
something a lot of those women are angry
man a lot I'm more angry and so I think
but if you're taking a girl out to a
date and she like um how do you know if
a girl's a Leslie when you take her out
what do you guys think if she offers to
change the tire and pay for the meal and
do everything to do then [ __ ] you after
the meal probably that might be why that
might be wifey though my wifey for some
it sounds horrible to having to [ __ ] on
a full stomach
how you doing for a pasta dinner and
then I get a [ __ ] oh my girl I'll [ __ ]
on a Saturday morning and that's it
empty empty stomach after a run catch me
the next life
yeah I'm that reincarnation [ __ ] honey
you can catch me next time don't feed me
a whole cheese pizza and expect me to
lay it down yeah slap it like Derek
don't what happening but don't feed me a
cheese pizza and call me big Randy you
know what I'm saying
yeah I do and that won't be me a
footlong sub and expect my footlong it
ain't happenin bro I got a full stomach
you feel me yeah barely feel yeah let's
go what were you gonna say Ken how do
you know if she sucks [ __ ] or not well
first of all we don't say policy on here
what do we say huh what she already said
tits and that was good pal got it tits
were good all right why I want to
emphasize the cat people know it's hot
it's hard to tell hawkgirl summer I got
a romp run mm-hmm maybe you should hook
up with a lesbian chick and see if she
goes straight afterwards you know why he
can't though I think he keeps taking
women out he's basically lesbians
they're not like gay dudes like they're
not even gonna [ __ ] with a dick dude
girl you take out is just a lesbian
you're at the it sounds like you might
just be um which one of the people that
shows you around school with the
beginning of school when you get there
an RA no it's um it's kind of like that
but it's like remember you come to
school a few days early in the end
around ya you might just be or do work
for the orientation sounds like you are
you new to campus you think you're
trying to [ __ ] everybody they're just
not into it and dude if you taking a
lesbian out brah you need to also I
would get a female wig on yeah I'll try
and run the threesome game you know I'm
saying he can't get a 1 some dude
yeah but she's into other girls you like
do let's toss some guy oh that's a good
idea
awesome [ __ ] in the wrench no she's in
other barrels I know but why not have
him in there but I think if you're a guy
and a girl won't hook up with you you
can't be like hey not only don't hook up
with me don't hook up with me and my
buddy it's a tough game dude welcome to
know what I like this guy he likes a
challenge yeah thank you and uh mission
impossible as I call it right you've
been drinking diesel out of some of them
food trucks there you know [ __ ] yeah you
might dude strikes again yeah you might
be right dude the only reason I started
this show because I thought Thiel was a
lesbian and so hot right now I find out
he's not the hot girls yeah whatever
dude I'm into chicks both the tits boy
to tits hey whatever bro yeah now we all
believe that I'm into those double dead
chicks boy find me around some teat ties
boy and some cooter son like a champion
no failure this guy wishes he could get
there good luck man quit hollering that
lesbians though you feel me yeah you'll
be fine dude what's your problem dude
you're playing baseball everyone else
playing football switch it up bro you're
the wrong game yeah I think if you're
only catching lesbians you got to change
your bait you know yeah yeah maybe it's
the way you dress dude
yeah maybe wear some maybe wear like a
football t-shirt or something or a
jersey you know let them know you're a
straight heterosexual man yes right now
you might be throwing mixed signals but
it might have a romper on yeah put some
elk on put a little bit elk on you know
spray a little elk [ __ ] [ __ ] on your
neck yeah they get your beef jerky and
just [ __ ] put it behind the ears a
little bit so these [ __ ] know you
smell like Slim Jim
yeah drove a little bit of year piss a
deer piss on a Becky a bald head yeah
no I'm saying show your work boy don't
just get to the answer show you work
take a little gravy put it on your
[ __ ] tits dude I love that man that's
me you're making stuff up are you right
too much what else do you do you guys
gonna rip a little drip yeah we'll rip
some he sure has that all we been doing
I feel like all we do is just make fun
of people and then go home I feel like I
feel like we make fun of each other and
everyone else somebody say feel like we
help that guy out he's gonna get his
wardroom like you know I am dressing
like a lesbian what else you got dude
I'll tell you this yeah and if the
alleged minutes keep coming at you boy
then you know I'm gonna suck your dick
fight him bro no dude don't fight him
tuck your dick though sometimes you
gotta be gonna hit a [ __ ] of the body
my buddy got beat up by two lesbians
dude last month that arm outside of a
crystal burger well he probably deserved
it dude no he didn't why what'd he do
huh he didn't do anything he was looking
for something outside of his car he
dropped something and they just beat him
up yeah those lesbians are rough to do
switch for the butch kind yeah gotta hit
a [ __ ] to the body liver shot don't hit
him the face you go with those liver
shots boy yeah good cus important liver
shot breast and Poirier dude in two
rounds son gonna beat that ass and go
back to the hotel earlier breath I hope
you're right saying a boy first this is
Ivan Cardenas this is Ivan damn this is
rip my drip rip my drip talking about
kedo kid lost 100 pounds being Kito for
two years Congrats man that's amazing
bro yeah that's life transforming it
right there and what else Derek that's
it well he weighed through 65 at five
nine look at him now look at this guy I
was a ziwei now burnin let's test him
all dude 165 was shredding buh-buh-buh
shredded twisted seal bro he is [ __ ]
bodied up now man oh he looks like a
seal that does cocaine at the end bro he
definitely looks really knows look he
was like a cheetah with glasses right
there dude he looks like definitely like
a guy who's kind of like nerdy but sexy
like he's doing crystal math you know
he's doing drugs but also really smart
yeah like reason bro needs a lot can but
else get high as [ __ ] yeah he's been
smoking that crystal man it looks like
using inject and [ __ ] gravy into a
stomach on the left there
well I'm afraid my [ __ ] was thick
that's how he got that lasagna hit her
right there bro he was Jerry Rice at
Lambert's home of the throwed rolls can
you bring that restaurant up for us real
quick landlord school dude Lambert Janna
and yet he looks like he owns a Sbarro's
on the left is there Sbarro's out here
are we familiar with Sbarro's pizza I
don't know where you're from
Sbarro's you know what it is it's s Baro
is the one that's in the airport
sometimes in the report yeah you're
right
yeah first of all if you eat it a s
borrows and it's not in the airport then
you're going to hell yes yeah it's
nobody eats at them here we go Lambert's
right there rolls home with a throat
rolls but I ever been there
Missouri no never been there now
Lambert's what they do is you sit
anywhere in there and you call for a
roll bro and from behind the counter dat
[ __ ] boy it's a nice home huh it's a
nice roll beautiful breads brother is it
butternut buttered up to oh dude now if
you want I don't catch em butter broad
catch them dry and then a butter on
myself you know I know how long to tell
that [ __ ] iced up hitter towards my
honey you're like Balu it's a bear
necessity your simple bare necessities
yeah you're like Balu do you can you
can't catch a buttered roll bro I'm down
though you know I cannot butcher this
dry bread but you do playboy and I
butter them hoes myself but this guy
looks like Jerry Rice on the left of the
Lambert's home of the throwed rolls bro
like he was setting records bro just
catching them rolls right Monday to
Friday yeah
now he's mr. steal your girl on the
right he is shred city dude proud of him
man that's the real Quito kid you know
hard that is the real man bro two years
bro he looks like yeah it looks like you
changed [ __ ] ethnicities
yeah he's Muslim on the Left Mexican on
the right really to me more yeah I could
see uh I don't know man I don't even
know looks good though I don't know
about that I mean looks like a nice guy
I mean he's looks healthier
I'm not gonna say he looks good dude you
know what I'm saying cuz I got you know
I want to have a family and stuff I feel
you all right what else we got I forgot
before every deficit I feel like my I'm
waiting for my car to get fixed and it's
just like wait for it to get fixed so we
can lead like Jesus Christ right how
long would it take him to fix this
[ __ ] thing bro it was just a
windshield wiper replacement after two
nights
it was a it was a slow leak on my tire
dude by just taking three hours but he
is this brother I got him kiss her he
got arrested we saw a lady get arrested
from steroid it up Theo and who are we
ripping the guy on the right on the Left
right here it's two guys this is a young
lady but look at this cop right here I
mean that guy does look a little feel
ish who the no guy yeah yeah I am jacked
dude if I'm a cop the guys Jackson only
slim down for comedy that make sense
that's what I'm trying to do bro I
leaned out for the humor but yeah yeah I
was jacked and I was on the force dude
that was me boy we get to patrolling it
really does I feel like it looks like
probably actually it looks a little
later older brother that made better
decisions your older brother where you
can have two beers and not go to rehab
[Laughter]
Ezra good call I will say this he also
looked a little bit though like John
Cena a little bit like Bruce Banner that
used to play the original incredible
hole oh you're right with a little bit
of touch of the downs yeah he's got a
touch of that tizen but uh looks like if
you're a proud boy he's gonna beat the
[ __ ] out of you too you don't want to
come around his way either brah he looks
like he'll do some protein right off
your freakin butthole some protein
powder right so that [ __ ] whey
protein right off your neck Oh yummy oh
he'll drain your new yeah Iranian newts
of some grams of frickin wet protein
yeah boys bodied up look at that right
now
look out biggest digby do you think he
has on you think he has pants I don't
think he needs guns dude if the guy's
underpants on or would it now you have
to blood ass at the back oh dude what
are you ruin everything
what am I
we're talking about how Jack this dude
is look how [ __ ] driven support the
police look it is falling over here J
you don't feel some ham hocks out the
back of that Dallas [ __ ] police force
dude I talk about the Dallas Cowboys
this bro he's the [ __ ] real Jerry
Jones hitter here oh they should sign
him right now he's tied in
bro definitely I bet this guy's Mesa I
bet he has different flavors of mace bro
different flavor proteins a mace this
guy definitely seemed like a nice guy
yeah he does I wish she was protecting
me at all times looking for her you
being homoerotic right bro I'm headed to
Dallas I want to met the shows to
protect me talk to me at night maybe
give me a drive around every story you
talk about some dude ends up busting all
over you by the end of it this ain't fit
name on my church you should sell some
honey mustard what else we got alright
boys I end it with a little king under
sting okay hold on
bless you feel I'm back first this is
Raziel from London you'll feel your
Brendan go quick King you'll see a few
guys foot fetches what do you think as a
foot connoisseur I've been wondering
myself what a soccer these deep pictures
of camp let me know help brother out
also do see you in September
Brendan plaintively gonna see you man
but keep up the good work I love to hear
and yeah gang getting buzz-buzz
he said Gang Gang first I'd like to say
that but is that he I won't be there in
September man but I will be there later
on I just don't wanna where's he I think
that he's in London and he's um he's a I
guess British he's in London night he's
one of those he's English you ain't dumb
[ __ ] huh damn it man Why What did he
say nothing you call him a London night
and he called him a British shite I
don't know it's like I get Dumber coming
here and I need all the brains do it all
I'll say is tell him Scotland is free
brother I've never been in two feet
really and the cat came around
the hottest feat in the game you know
it's a lot of money dude a cat always
lands on his feet let's hear from the
foot stress herself I mean how about the
horses what is is great I understand the
fascination to certain people's extent
of pain for pictures of nice feet
personally thank you we could look up
people's feet online every celebrity has
like their own wiki's like sandals and
[ __ ] yeah would you my feet are hideous
are your school oh we're talking about
women's feet right now
listen all right you're right back in
her jacket that's feet yeah that's what
we're talking about yeah Cal Kent would
you sell pictures of your feet or not
she could make so much money doing it
had a whole game plan for and she didn't
want to do it well let her answer yeah
go ahead
I truly believe that my feet are meant
for is meant for marriage the
institution of marriage that's the one
thing just a few to keep sacred oh wow
see my relationship oh wow oh [ __ ]
you're serious cat yeah I'm dead serious
yeah what are you really yeah oh I
thought she was a Zico leaf [ __ ] you
probably went back on your man beat the
[ __ ] out of her with these feet look if
you want to put it in her tarsals bro
he's got that big toe girl yeah I've
never been a foot guy but then cat came
around she's covering the puppies up you
never been a foot guide never been a big
foot guy Wow you like feet yeah dude I
was like dammit women stand on feet and
have feet bro I don't think that women
just float in the air
you're an idiot man let's go I will say
that a woman's foot says a lot about her
and how well she takes care of herself
though Creech if you don't take care of
your feet you're probably you're
probably not taking care of others oh
you write like a little sad on that foot
I like a little bit of paint on the end
but a hard part of the okay well I don't
mind a little bunion out the back oh
you're putting work girl no I'm saying I
got some friends who work in the
nightlife injury their feet are [ __ ]
up cuz I can't see em high heels [ __ ]
popping bottles then working hard making
that cash oh I wouldn't mind a good foot
massage man you had a good foot massage
oh yeah
heaven on earth dude and they're tough
to find dude sometimes that AUSA Cara
she gives massages online really ah dude
I pay hot massages brash for that what
those aren't massages dude watching
somebody masturbate no the massages do
should jack off with her feet oh oh
next we got Erin from Colorado
Brendan Theo I'm here in Brendan's home
state Colorado beautiful got a question
for ya Wow rock climbing
King under sting it Gang Gang what a
great I agree those creative men dude
rock climbing real badass you ever tried
climbing rocks yeah my sister used to do
drugs and she'd climb Rock climbed up to
a nudist colony in Arizona
Ron they stayed for lunch they were on
drugs her and some guy she was seeing
what's her feet like ah I'm all about
rock climbing you ever see the what was
the documentary the solo bird where the
[ __ ] you was free solo you ever see Hope
Solo scooter pics on the Internet
free dude said yellow me a sexy pic she
said cool [ __ ] so aggressive dude and
her feet she got some flappers just
slice 15 I don't think it was a foot
brother state they're the best I'll see
you in to the September by the way
Comedy Works you have a beautiful state
their brother in Colorado and what was
this question
rock climbing King understand oh yeah
real badass and strong is fun rock climb
is cool they got those jams Rica climb
and REI bro yeah and dress up and uh and
yeah it's very exciting I think it's a
nice thing you're doing with somebody
that you care about back there you got a
little lady in the back right you have
to trust her you know I'm saying yeah
rock climbing def linking you'll be a
real bad
rock climbs and really trustworthy dude
think about this bro
you don't like your mate that much y'all
go out there because you have to have
the other person helps you so much right
now with the belaying and stuff so let's
climb up first and put the rope in you
know I'm saying
whoops beer growls yeah this is the this
is the new cruise to Aruba this is a new
Dominican Republic right here rock
climbing and go rock climb yeah taking a
rock climbing and come back on tinder
yeah I'm surprised more people don't do
that do ya
it's I mean how could you prove it yeah
I know it's a brilliant idea I murder
somebody yeah good thank you watch the
two years from now do we have to testify
in a case because somebody who are learn
that on this show try not to rock
climbing last one boys this is Monta
Amundsen and what a great name for
somebody rock climbing
every mouth stuff like this
[Music]
Gill's by the way qinger singing Gang
Gang buzzbuzz buzzbuzz dude what are you
so angry about
he doesn't seem angry bro he seems safe
does he yeah that music is so intense
but he is wearing bright green that's a
safe color nothing gonna happen ever if
you just get done with some sort of
marathon bright scream okay to be a
marathon man though you feel me oh no
you don't know crusher runs does he oh
yeah yeah that's true all the time yeah
voice thick uh screamo musics hard to
deal with sometimes um I don't know I
don't listen to it for me it's too
intense I got enough screaming music
inside of my brain I got my own screamo
soundtrack going on my head and threaten
me [ __ ] nuts yeah it's also way too
violent man scream oh I used to listen
to that uh ska music when I was young we
would go to go to mosh pits you know
like some band would always start up
like horn like Skinny Puppy or just like
her you know some weird name like hurt
grandparent or something and they would
have two songs and they would play them
nine times in a row you know mosh pit it
would just be people mosh pitting that's
all it was and then somebody would get
hurt and then like I know yeah and they
put yet they put calamine lotion on you
and [ __ ] dragged you out yeah [ __ ] yeah
no it was it was like a sense of
camaraderie and stuff that I really
really did miss about it just like being
in mosh pits and stuff like that but
didn't some [ __ ] always came through
mosh pit was really like early UFC for
some people yeah and then also it was
like kind of like a brotherhood for
other people then some people started
training for the mosh pit [ __ ] people
up did like Ray Lewis in the mosh pit
what are we doing man
why are you six four two and seventy
pounds we're kids yeah it's tough do
people still mosh
I know is it still a thing oh yeah we're
trying to walk that Travis Scott concert
they were mom Travis Colin like
everything oh yeah they're Martian avoid
like they make the circle they spring up
and then when the song drops they
[ __ ] charge each other do kids are
crazy
see black kids doing it really they were
black i'ma said the blacks I saw that
race is that racist no no I'm gonna keep
safely moccasin Blackie's was it like a
safe my vibe you know black - yes I'm
athletic dude run for four oh you mean
it's the Pittsburgh Steelers Baltimore
Ravens is that what you mean that was a
[ __ ] a sicko concert the Cool
Runnings of Maz Pittsburgh Wow yeah were
they jumping over each other and [ __ ] oh
they were backflip that was crazy dude
anytime it's an athletic event white
people are doing it black we will let me
see that take over bro except for
there's some events it's not like that
hockey rock climbing swimming swimming
hockey swimming rock black lava as they
call it
so what else what else
horse UFC John Jones best fighter on
planet Earth neo stick one last the
other night doesn't matter but black
black people passed though black buddies
he owned drugs though well no he passed
the last test then one out of 20
anyway so pass five percentage Johnson
before that though you're right I mean
but I don't know why people dominate
though well I think it's a fair I think
that's a sport where it's Brazilians for
a while dominate white dudes are coming
back in the NBA with a lot of the
European basketball players a little bit
really are there and my kids are getting
softer some of them you're starting to
see mixed black dudes brah Ben Simmons
will never [ __ ] in my heart rot hold
a candle to [ __ ] my boy Sam Perkins
or Charles oh oh not even close it's
just getting a little on starkwood run
circles around him two generations
you're gonna have like a guy looks just
like Jon start with black skin and like
both white John stark hair and it's
gonna be really that's what everyone
anyway even yet yeah you're right the
NBA is softest [ __ ] those Europeans
coming over pretty gang joke itch bad
boy bra right you MVP dude I was talking
to Blake Griffin right about just asking
him I said does any player still smoke
cigarettes and all yeah and he said he
goes man there was a player that I play
with a couple years ago I can't remember
the guys name
he goes and he was a chain smoker and I
think he anybody was a good player
player he was from Croatia I think and
he goes but at a certain point after the
second season they're like hey you can't
but it'd be crazy cuz you'd be on the
court a lot de la Vida box smoke so yeah
playing a pro sportive smoke as
cigarettes brought those are the real
champions who are those guys who I want
to know in Eastwood other sports league
you don't play on drugs bro Lawrence
Taylor okay dude what's that [ __ ] the
receiver who keeps [ __ ] I glare oh no
Michael Irvin was always high Ricky who
played for the Gras Ricky no thanks no
the Celtics the basketball player Ricky
Adams no Ricky green no Ricky Henderson
had to been on some coca you know fast
he was around the base you think
sometimes you watch people like too fast
yeah yeah yeah I think they should
legalize cocaine for some of the games
but they make it fun for the preseason
just the team yeah gram these dogs up
dying three man limb to how the PD Oh
ped up bro yeah they should have a PE D
League bro they do thank you guys gang
man ah
we did it brother buzz you me shooting a
movie huh
so no tour dates for a little bit yeah
no tour dates I will still be in Biloxi
I mean but yeah I'm just sorry that I
had to cancel some of these other dates
but I'm gonna make them up don't be
sorry brother you got a great
opportunity and the fans know it yeah
good you'll be back you make it up you
ain't going nowhere
yeah just feel bad I guess yeah your
sellout not go anywhere thanks man I
know you are appreciate I'm really proud
of you dude always supportive I didn't
want to retweet the picture because of
the announcement on deadline because I
don't like the pictures I don't picture
either
sounds like ah because I thank you
that's why I want
here's a thousand pictures why not use a
current picture yeah so I didn't tweet
it that's how [ __ ] hate Hollywood bro
me too bro pictures prior to ask me to
do the movie directly that's why I'm
doing it I didn't go through any
[ __ ] am i dealing with these [ __ ]
hos and still Hollywood sold out but
listen that's not what this is about
I'm here but duty said we're gonna fight
aliens that's what he said one star
because as to go to the future to fight
aliens do you want to come help me
that's what he said dude I would have
really beat aliens before he did he's
done a few times Gardens a gallon right
so he did be the t-rex Jurassic Park son
twice ain't rolling it in a future with
some [ __ ] half-wit rolling up there
with uh Jack Black you do know you can't
do that bro
so I got a roll in there with a real
hitter can't do what Seth Rogen oh
saying I don't know the [ __ ] hitter I
ain't losing to a couple of [ __ ] bald
eagles like Seth Rogen the only way I
roll up is with hitters man same is here
dude
weird ugh gang proudiy man thanks bro
Dustin the diamond Poirier in two rounds
do take that bar I hope you're right bro
man bruh Daggerfall broke that's what
I'm saying let's see it go right down at
the jewelry stove son diamonds diamond
bro let's get some diamonds uh me man
I'm gonna be in Houston 20th and 21st
love you September Houston improv Big D
we'll be there slapping and then I'll be
in Denver end of month September get
your tickets tik Tom oh yeah and that's
it man I'll reschedule the Tour de said
I do have to change I think we're gonna
go to Europe in January and thank you
guys for math learn April are you
where does this King in the stink tour
gonna happen because after this tour I'm
doing eye makeup these dates I hey bro
bro what's up bro damn do you got some
[ __ ] tits right man what's up rose
[ __ ] yeast infection bro you got tits
daddy
it looks like I'm allergic these things
are some shits
look at this slick rabbit is it loose
don't touch me bro but keep like a
jewellery shop you got by your nipples
why don't you get some honey mustard out
mr. yam Indiana jonesing for a Cleveland
steamer dawg
[Music]
the king must
[Music]